hey 42 here as a child Albert Einstein
was a very slow learner and he spoke
very slowly so much so that his parents
actually feared that he may have
learning difficulties thankfully it
turned out that couldn't be further from
the truth here's some amazing facts you
probably didn't know about the man who
spearheaded the theory of relativity and
the world's most renowned genius Albert
Einstein was born in Ulm in Germany on
the 14th of March 1879 it is said that
the story of Einstein's brilliant
started when he was just four years old
his father gave him a magnetic pocket
compass to play with he became obsessed
of the way that the needle seemed to
move around as if by magic
it's believed that was the event from
where Einstein's deep passion for
physics originated even as an old man
Einstein wrote about the compass saying
I can still remember that the experience
made a deep and lasting impression on me
something deeply hidden has to be behind
things
Einstein became a professor at the
Berlin Academy of Sciences however in
1933 he was visiting America just as
Hitler came into power back in
Einstein's home country of Germany being
born to Jewish parents he rightfully
force it would not be a good idea to
return to Germany the Nazis were so
offended by Einsteins intellect that
they burned all his books are still
remained in Germany and included him on
a list of enemies of the Nazi state
entitled not yet hanged and put a $5,000
bounty on his head
Einstein responded to the Nazis by
calling their actions a spontaneous
emotional outburst and stating that more
than anything else in the world they
fear the influence of men of
intellectual independence Einstein was
granted refugee status and became a
citizen of the United States of America
where he stayed for the remainder of his
life
Einstein considered himself to be
agnostic not an atheist
he criticized personal gods ie
gods that are believed to resemble a
human form
Einstein instead had pantheistic beliefs
which is the idea that the universe and
nature itself is equal to divinity as
opposed to an anthropomorphic or
human-like God
Einstein was well known for his iconic
shabby look which consisted of wild
uncombed hair and baggy oversized
clothes also he never wore socks
he saw Sox's unnecessary and got
frustrated that whenever he wore socks
he got holes in them
he wouldn't even wear socks or comb his
hair when visiting the White House also
part of Einsteins look was his pipe eye
Stein loved to smoke whether it be
cigarettes cigars or his iconic pipe
which was his favorite method of tobacco
inhalation when he walked between his
house and his office at Princeton
University he would almost always be
seen leaving a trail of smoke behind him
Einstein once had the following to say
on the matter I believe that pipe
smoking contributes to a somewhat calm
and objective judgment in all human
affairs it was well known by everyone
that knew him not Einstein had an
incredibly bad memory he couldn't
remember most people's names and
couldn't even remember any phone numbers
including his own in 1952 after Israel's
first president Chaim Weizmann died
Einstein was offered the position of
Israel's presidency because the Israelis
believed him to be the greatest Jew
alive Einstein then aged 73 politely
declines the offer he said that he liked
the natural aptitude and the experience
to deal properly with people Einstein
used to charge people for his autograph
then donate all of the money to charity
Einstein was a prolific adulterer during
his first marriage to Mileva Maric
Albert had at least six affairs with
other women knowing that his marriage
was falling apart
Einstein made one final attempt at
keeping them out together for the sake
of his children so what did he do
exactly he demanded his wife signed a
contract which he drew up in order to
maintain the impression that they were
still a happily married couple
the
tract included the following clauses you
will make sure that's my clothes and
laundry are kept in good order that I
will receive my free meals regularly in
my room you will renounce all personal
relations with me insofar as they are
not completely necessary for social
reasons specifically you will forego my
sitting at home with you by going out or
traveling with you you will obey the
following points in your relations with
me you will not expect any intimacy from
me nor will you've approached me in any
way you will stop talking to me if I
request it you will leave my bedroom or
study immediately without protest if I
request it wait to be tactful Albert
amazingly his wife actually agreed to
the terms after much persuasion after he
divorced Mileva Maric in 1919 Einstein
married his cousin Elsa Lowenthal
she was very closely related to Einstein
he was actually related to her on both
sides of his family they have played
together much as kids but their romance
didn't fully flourish until later on in
both their lives
Einstein's favorite hobbies were sailing
and playing the violin but never came
close to his love for for ethical
physics Einstein would often play the
violin to himself when he he became
stuck in the thinking process whilst
practicing physics the prestigious Nobel
Prize was awarded to Albert Einstein in
1921 but not for his work on the theory
of relativity he actually got it for his
work on helping to discover the
photoelectric effect which is now the
well known phenomenon that metals emit
electrons when light is shined upon them
however all of Einstein's Nobel prize
money went to his ex wife Mileva as a
divorce settlement about a week after
Einstein died in 1955 at Princeton
before being cremated an autopsy was
performed on his body by Thomas Harvey
pathologist at Princeton University
he removed Einsteins brain for study
which he intended to keep permanently as
a keepsake and personal research prod
Harvey was eventually fired from
Princeton after refusing to hand over an
Stein's brain after finding it wasn't
any different to a normal brain Harvey
dissected it into over 200 pieces some
of which he sent off to other
researchers for examination it was
eventually discovered that Einsteins
parietal lobes the parts of the brain
responsible for mathematical visual and
spatial cognition were 15% larger than
the average person's Einstein's brain
was eventually transferred and put on
display at the Mutter Museum in
Philadelphia
his eyes however were also removed and
handed to Henry Abrams Einstein's eye
doctor to this day they remain in a safe
deposit box in New York
Einstein's last words are not no because
he said them in German and the only
person that heard them was a night nurse
who only spoke English what all of these
facts pale in comparison to the most
amazing fact about Albert Einstein in
1905 whilst working in Bern Switzerland
Einstein published a paper on his
special theory of relativity which
challenged the world's idea of how space
and time behaves in the universe and set
the tone of theoretical physics for the
next century uncounted the ideas
Einstein put forward in his
revolutionary paper had enormous
consequences that completely changed the
way we think about mass energy space and
time oh and by the way Einstein
published over 300 scientific papers
over his lifetime his paper on the
special theory of relativity also
included what has become the most famous
equation in the world e equals MC
squared otherwise known as the mass
energy equivalence
on a very basic level it is the concept
that the mass of any object is a measure
of how much energy is contained within
it there was actually numerous
scientists who all claimed to have
discovered the equation around the same
time but it was eventually decided that
Albert Einstein should be given the
credit for it as he put the most effort
into its discovery
e equals mc-squared gave rise to the
atomic bomb and the nuclear arms race
knowing that he was mostly responsible
for causing the atomic bombs eventual
discovery Einstein slipped into a period
of great depression he believed himself
to be a pacifist in 1915 Einstein
completed his general theory of
relativity which implied the existence
of black holes and gravitational waves
as well as many other things up until
which point had been nothing more than
hypotheses together with his special
theory of relativity Einstein's general
theory of relativity formed the theory
of relativity the cornerstone of modern
physics and arguably the most important
discovery in physics of the past century
sure the theory of relativity is used
everyday by physicists in their
increasingly complex endeavors but its
effects can be seen in our everyday
lives too none of the following things
will be possible without an Stein's two
theories of relativism GPS systems
televisions nuclear power plants
remote-control devices
lasers DVD players and many offers oh
and I almost forgot to mention the
universe itself thanks for the view
subscribe for more 42
you